good morning believe nation today's
message is the only person stopping you
is you over to you Duncan Bannatyne as
from this moment you be the phenomenal
opportunity and every single one of you
can have a life and have a great life
and have money and have a privileged
future the only person stopping you is
you I think one of the big things that
differentiate people who are successful
from the ones who aren't is that they
take responsibility the people who have
achieved great things take
responsibility for their life they stop
blaming others and the ones who don't
quite hit it or the ones who live in
mediocrity the people who are upset that
they can't hit their goals are the ones
who blame other people right they blame
their parents they blame the school they
blame their government they can't be
successful because Obama is the
president they can't be successful
because you know tax rates are too high
they can't be successful because they
didn't come from a rich family and the
list of excuses go on and on and on and
on and on there's nothing wrong with you
you're perfect
it's everybody else's fault that you're
not successful we're the ones who are
successful the ones who actually go out
and hit their goals are the ones who
realize that the cavalry is not coming
that they don't need to rely on somebody
else's actions for them to get to where
they want to go they take responsibility
for their life if you're unhappy with
how people are treating you that's on
you you're letting them treat you that
way anything that is happening right now
that it's happening to you that you're
upset about you have let happen to you
and you need to own it you need to take
responsibility to start making changes
and when you do take responsibility
that's when that's when you start to
take off that's when you start to
realize that the world is much greater
and that you can actually do a lot of
these big things when you understand
that it's on you to make
it happened for me hitting my million
subscriber go on YouTube that's on me
right like I need to get better I
recognize that I need to get better I
need to get better in picking the clips
I need to get better in what I say on
camera afterwards
I need to turn it up I need to give a
better message to you guys and yes you
know we could have more lighting or
different cameras or different editing
and all this thing is easy for me to
blame other people right it's easy for
me to blame my team and say hey we're
not here because you guys didn't do this
it's on me and even it was a team's
fault I hired that team it's on me to
find the new team right it's on you
whatever your goal is if you haven't
reached it yet the only reason is the
person that's looking back at you in the
mirror and until you understand that
until you embody that and to fully
realize that as long as you continue to
blame others for your failures then
you're never going to get to where you
want to be the only person holding you
back is you so the question today today
is I want to know how are you holding
yourself back going a little deeper
today leave in the comments below I'll
join the discussion thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events press